[Música]
un giro extraordinario en la campaña
presidencial tras ser diagnosticado con
kobe 19 donald trump fue trasladado al
hospital militar walter reed donde
pasará unos días sufre de cansancio pero
está de buen ánimo a poco más de un mes
de las elecciones presidenciales la
campaña de tromba tiene que posponer
mítines y otros eventos programados con
el mandatario
argentina añadió a su sistema nacional
de vigilancia de salud tres mil
cincuenta muertes por kobe 19 que se
encontraban pendientes y la cantidad de
fallecidos superan ya a los 20 mil 200
los positivos en el país desde que se
inició la pandemia ya son 765 mil
personas
sexto día de combates en la región
separatista de nagorno karabaj o una
enclave situado en territorio
azerbaiyano pero poblado por armenios
armenia ofreció un cese del fuego pero
azerbaiyán no cambia de parecer y
reclama la retirada de las tropas
armenias de la región ambos países
acusan al otro y utilizar mercenarios
extranjeros
muy buena noche gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 se redoblan
con gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo en eeuu donde se conoció que
el presidente de donaldson y su esposa
melanie a dieron positivo para kobe 19
tras sentirse fatigado y con una leve
fiebre el mandatario fue trasladado
junto con la primera mamá melania al
hospital militar walter vida por
recomendación médica y como medida de
precaución donde permanecerán varios
días según los médicos tramos seguirá
ejerciendo sus labores oficiales como
comandante en jefe la noticia se conoce
a poco más de un mes de las elecciones
presidenciales estadounidenses la
campaña de reelección del mandatario
afirmó que por el momento los actos
previstos se cancelan o se realizarán de
manera virtual trump habló antes de su
traslado al hospital escuchemos
quiero agradecer a todo el mundo por el
respaldo tremendo voy al hospital walter
reed creo que me encuentro muy bien pero
vamos a asegurarnos que todo está bien
la primera dama se encuentra muy bien
muchas gracias estoy muy agradecido y
nunca voy a olvidar gracias
no es cuestión de política es un
recordatorio de que todos nosotros
debemos tomarnos este virus en serio no
va a desaparecer automáticamente tenemos
que hacer nuestra parte y ser
responsables significa seguir la ciencia
escuchar a los expertos lavarnos las
manos y mantener distancia social
significa usar una máscara en público y
alentar a otros a que también lo hagan
ahí escuchaban también entonces yo bailé
en candidato demócrata a la presidencia
estadounidense pero para ampliar esa
información quiero saludar en ese
momento a nuestra corresponsal en la
capital washington dice diana castañeda
diana que es lo último que se sabe sobre
la salud del presidente de trump y la
primera gama melania
hola buenas noches pues el presidente
será tratado en el hospital walter beer
por algunos de los síntomas que está
presentando entre ellos molestia en la
garganta fatiga también se sabe según lo
ha dicho la casa blanca y su doctor
personal que ha sido sometido a un
tratamiento experimental no aprobado aún
por la sda para tratar estos síntomas y
para el coronavirus también que se le
está dando vitamina de zinc y aspirina
otros de los aspectos importantes es que
el presidente va a permanecer en
cuarentena en el hospital y que también
se espera que desde allí pues realice
algunas de sus funciones pero no
funciones que están relacionadas con la
campaña como tal ahora tiene usted ya lo
mencionó de cara a estas elecciones que
ocurre con los eventos y actividades
para su compañía reelección y cómo
podría más afectar esto
bueno pues básicamente sería el
vicepresidente mike pence quien ha dado
negativo al igual que su esposa esta
prueba de coronavirus quien llevaría el
liderazgo en estos eventos de campaña
aunque eventos relacionados con recaudar
fondos como en el cual participó el
presidente el día de ayer con varias
personas en un evento en 'new jersey'
estos eventos ya no los realizará no se
sabe si los hará de manera virtual y
también hay cuestionamientos sobre si el
presidente podrá llegar a atender en un
futuro algún debate adicional como el
que vimos con su contrincante demócrata
joe biden quien también se hizo la
prueba y resultó negativo al igual que
su esposa es posible que también sus
hijos puedan llevar digamos la vocería
de estos eventos ya que su hija ivanka
trump y su esposo han dado negativo
también a la prueba de coronavirus
brevemente día de muchos
cuestionamientos sobre si el presidente
podrá seguir ejerciendo sus funciones
que dice la constitución al respecto
bueno que el presidente ha dicho que va
a continuar ejerciendo sus funciones la
constitución en la enmienda 25 establece
que si un presidente como tal no puede
ejercer estas funciones sería el
vicepresidente quien sería juramentado
como presidente de los eeuu pero en dado
caso de que el presidente llegara a
recuperarse después de estar en esta
enfermedad pues entonces ésta sería una
transición temporal pero por el momento
el presidente como vimos camino al
helicóptero que lo llevó al hospital y
dice que está optimista gracias diario
por la información por supuesto vamos a
estar muy pendientes a lo que ocurra con
la salud del presidente donald trump
famosas argentinas porque ese país
superó el umbral de las 20 mil muertes
por kobe 19 luego de sumar tres mil
cincuenta fallecimientos que no habían
sido contabilizados hasta el momento con
14 mil nuevos casos el país confirma una
tendencia al alza de la enfermedad que
ahora se propaga con fuerza fuera de
buenos aires a esta situación se suman
protestas como las de los enfermeros por
las precarias condiciones laborales
el cómic 19 se dispara en argentina
el país sudamericano que supo contener
el brote al inicio de la pandemia con un
confinamiento total registra un
incremento de casos y fallecimientos
este viernes se fueron sumadas tres mil
cincuenta muertes correspondientes en la
provincia de buenos aires- que no habían
sido computadas así los decesos superan
los veinte mil tenemos una tasa de
letalidad del 27 por ciento con respecto
al total de los casos confirmados y una
tasa de mortalidad específica por
coronavirus que asciende a 447 personas
por cada millón de habitantes mientras
en la ciudad de buenos aires- las cifras
se han estabilizado el virus se propaga
con fuerza en el resto del país sobre
todo en provincias que durante meses
mantuvieron los casos bajo control
en esta situación nos crecen las quejas
de trabajadores sanitarios por las
precarias condiciones laborales el
jueves varias organizaciones de
enfermeros se realizaron una huelga de
24 horas para reclamar entre otras cosas
ser considerados como esenciales y
profesionales de la salud y por mejoras
salariales corremos riesgo todos los
días porque una terapia intensiva en
muchos pacientes infectados que no
arriesgan nuestra vida
bueno en nuestra profesión la elegimos
lo que pretendemos es una remuneración
lógica
según el ministerio de salud el
porcentaje de ocupación de las unidades
de terapia intensiva es de 61 6% a nivel
nacional una cifra que asciende por
encima del 80 por ciento en provincias
como rionegro en el centro sur del país
o salta en el norte
en el sexto día de combates en el
enclave de nagorno karabaj o en la
capital del enclave escenario de
conflicto armado entre azerbaiyán y
armenia fue bombardeada y armenia
ofreció un cese al fuego veamos el
siguiente informe
las calles de este pana care tienen las
cicatrices del bombardeo de la mañana en
la capital de la república
autoproclamada de nagorno karabaj varios
civiles habrían sido heridos el
territorio ubicado entre armenia y
azerbayán es un enclave de mayoría
étnica armenia en el territorio de
azerbaiyán en este conflicto latente la
violencia estalla regularmente pero es
la primera vez desde la guerra de los
años 90 en la que murieron 30.000
personas que la situación está tan tensa
ante la intensificación de los combates
armenia dice estar dispuesta a buscar
una solución diplomática aunque
seguiremos respondiendo de manera
enérgica y decidida a esta agresión
contra nagorno karabaj estamos
dispuestos a colaborar con los países
que copresiden el grupo de minsk de la
osce para restablecer un alto el fuego
basado en los acuerdos de 1994 y 1995
pero en el sexto día de combates un alto
el fuego parece poco probable el
ministerio de defensa armenio publicó
este vídeo en el que se ve a un
helicóptero azerbayano derribado sobre
nagorno karabaj en la capital de
azerbaiján bajo toque de queda las
autoridades siguen exigiendo la retirada
de las tropas armenias de la región de
farming yo construyo
armenia quiere ver el fin de esta
escalada armenia debe poner fin a la
ocupación basta esparta para echar más
leña al fuego ambos países acusan al
otro de utilizar mercenarios extranjeros
de hecho francia acusó a turquía de
haber enviado combatientes sirios
la unión europea sancionó de forma
inmediata a 40 autoridades bielorrusas
dentro de la lista de personas se
encuentran responsables de las fuerzas
policiales viceministros o altos cargos
del servicio secreto bielorruso entre
otros que no incluyen al presidente
lukashenko la decisión de no incluir al
mandatario del país es con la intención
de seguir en contacto con alguien de
belarús para impulsar el diálogo
político en respuesta del gobierno de
ming se anunció sanciones en represalia
contra el bloque de la unión europea
reino unido y canadá
de esta manera llegamos al final de la
información france24 continúa con
nosotros buena noche para todos
[Música]